[موسيقى]
ليه يختاروا لك ده كان يعني ما كنتش لاقي
الصراحه عنوان مناسب قوي للموضوع فاخترت
العنوان ده بما ان برضو معظمنا هنا يا
شباب مش مش اولياء امور فالموضوع هيبقى
يعني لذيذ
هاخدكم في رحله كده من
من ثانويه عامه
اقول للمرحله اللي انتم هتبقوا فيها
ورايحين لها على طول يعني طبعا باين من
الصوره جدا ان انا كنت مش هنا كنت في
السعوديه
كنت الصراحه طالب
دحيح قوي كنت اول الفصل قاعد قدام مش عارف
ايه درجات ومذاكره ومفتاح
وبطبيعه الحال الحمد لله كنت جاي مجموعه
عاليه جدا في الثانويه العامه
ودحيح هناك في السعوديه اسمها الدافور
اللي هو الشخص الدحيح اوي يعني فكنت واخد
اللقب ده الصراحه هناك
الفكره دائما كانت بعد وانا في عامه انا
مش زي معظمكم هنا انا مش شايف حاجه انا
يعني اللي هو احنا هنروح على فين وهنعمل
ايه والمجموع فين يعني موضوع بحر واسع
ولكن كنت بعمل عليا اللي هو انا عايز بس
اعدي يعني هاعمل علي اجيب درجات كويسه
واجيب ثانويه عامه نسبه حلوه وخلاص والحمد
لله كنت جايب تقريبا
98% حاجه كده
وبالمعادله جيت هنا في مصر مثلا كانت 97
او حاجه كده يعني في الرنج يعني
التخصص وده كان ده كان مرحله صعبه جدا انت
حلوه جدا عايز بقى تاخد ايه بقى هتدخل
هندسه طب حكومه خاصه عندك يعني عاليه
خصوصا انت جايب اوريدي مجموعه عالي انا
هاخدكم في الرحله دي بس فكره انه في دراسه
وحاليا هنبص برضو من الناحيه التانيه على
اليوتيوب مثلا او على الطريق انا كنا كنت
ماشي فيه الناحيه التانيه كنت على
اليوتيوب مثلا كنت مشاهد وكنت بتفرج زي اي
حد عمل لناس بتفرج عليهم اول ما ينزلوا
حاجات متابع جدا فيديوهات يوتيوب بشكل عام
وعندي ناس بيحبهم بتفرج عليهم
بس ما كانش قوي في دماغي ممكن ابقى في يوم
بعمل فيديوهات يعني
في مرحله الثانويه هنا وانا خلاص بختار
التخصص نسيت في الاخر على هندسه كنت دخلت
اكاديميه البحريه وفي اللحظه دي بقى وانا
عايز ادخل هندسه واكاديميه وبتاع هنا
هنتكلم على فكره الاختيار بقى اللي هو
انت اكيد مش عايش لوحدك عايش مع اهلك
فبالتالي طب في ناس تقول لك طب ما تبص مش
عارف ايه ومش عارف ايه الخلاصه انا جات لي
فرصه ادخل جامعه في السعوديه
ببلاش هندسه بس انا اخترت انا انزل مصر
بارادتي عايز انزل مصر عشان كنت شايف ان
مصر فيها فرص تقدم بالنسبه لي اسرع بكتير
واحسن بكتير الاختيار ده كان مهم جدا ان
انا انا اللي اختاره فكره ان الاهل مش
بيفرضوا حاجه على
الاولاد او كده بيديهم فرصه اكتر ان هم
يختاروا دي حاجه مهمه انا بالنسبه لي فكره
انما والدي قال لي عندك ده وعندك ده وعندك
ده بس في الاخر انت هتشيل الليله هي في
اخر دي حياتك انت
فمتاكد عايز تنزل مصر تدخل هندسه
انت حر فرحت ودخلت طبعا باين اول فرق في
الصوره من دلوقتي
الشعر ما فيش
زيت عشرين كيلو مثلا او اكثر
كنت محافظ جدا على الرياضه كنت مركز جدا
بقى في الجامعه انا عارف انا عايز اعمل
ايه بالظبط انا داخل برضه الجامعه من نفس
الثانويه عامه مذاكره بس من الجامعه للبيت
من الاخر يعني
وبرضو متابع جدا اليوتيوب بشكل شرس يعني
لحد سنه ثالثه
اه ممكن نروح اه هنا بقى انا بدات اول
فيديو في يوتيوب يعني 2016
يوم 5 شهر 9
ده كان اول فلوج اعمله في حياتي انا كنت
نفسي يعني جيت فتره كده كنت بتفرج على كذا
وخصوصا كان اسمه
انا كنت يعني ما اتفرجت على الفيديوهات
انا عايز اعمل فيديوهات حسيت عايز اعمل
فيديوهات فعلا فكنت في التلات سنين دول
انا كنت بحوش مبلغ يعني ما بصرفش حاجه زي
ما قلت لكم الجامعه ده كله خدته كده
ورميته في كاميرا كانت كاميرا صغنونه كده
وهتعمل فيديوهات على اليوتيوب او انزل
فيديو اجيب 100 مشاهده موصوف جدا انا جبت
100 مشاهده النهارده يا جدعان انجاز
تاريخي لحد الفيديو ده لا ايوه الفيديو
احسن برجر في مصر انا طبعا يعني كنت اكيل
قوي وانا حتى ثانويه عامه كنت تخين جدا
كنت اتخن من كده مثلا ممكن 20 كيلو زياده
فانا اوريدي بيحب الاجابه بس انا عمري ما
دخلته في
محتوى اصلا لما دمجته الاتنين دول مع بعض
الفيديو زي ده فيديو طرقع جدا ما شاء الله
ضرب بس كده ارقام في حياتي يعني ايه اشوف
رقم 100,000 مشاهده ده ايه ده ده اعجاز
بعد كده ربع مليون في شهرين مثلا ثلاثه ده
كان بالنسبه لي انا اتخضيت من الرقم
بس قلت لا مش هعمل زي ما انا بعمل وبتاع
ومش عارف ايه والقناه وقتها حتى ما كانش
في الرقم ده كنت لسه حتى 10,000 لحد ما
يعني حد جيت فتره كده بعد كم شهر من
الفيديو ده كان في فيديو تاني بتاع فيديو
بيتزا
الفيدو وانا يعني هحط في السوق اشوف الناس
هتعمل اللي علينا عامل ازاي هعرف وقت انا
هعمل ايه
وقد كان نزلت الفيديو من هنا اسبوع ربع
مليون
ايه ده في ايه في حاجه هنا
محافظ على ايه فكره انه انا في الجامعه
وبذاكر وبتاع بس سنه ثالثه دي كانت
بالنسبه لي فكره يعني حاجه فاصله شويه ليه
يوتيوب بحاول في الجامعه عاديه جدا وفي
نفس الوقت بدخل شطلابي احتك المجتمع اكتر
بقى عايز اعرف الناس يعني عايشه ازاي انا
مش عايش في المجتمع انا كتاب بس ودي حاجه
مش حلوه فضلت كده مكمل في يوتيوب وجمع
يوتيوب وجامعه لحد ما جاء الحاجه اللي بعد
كده
فاتخرجت من الجامعه هنا بقى في السؤال
دايما
بتسالوني هل لو رجع بك الزمن
تدخل هندسه تاني مع ان انت اصلا دلوقتي
انت معكش دعوه خالص السؤال ده ممكن نجاوب
عليه في الاخر شويه بس لازم يعني خلوه في
الذاكره خلوه في الذاكره
اه فتره التخرج
دي كانت لحظه بالنسبه لي كانت حلوه جدا
الصراحه
انت خلاص هتخلص جامعه بتقدير عالي عندك
قناه نوعا ما شغاله
وخلصت طبيعي مهندس يعني ايه الجديد تمام
ما فيش مشكله هنا برضو في اختيار معين انت
هتكمل في ايه هتدخل عايز تسافر بره عايز
تكمل فقير بتاعك عايز تلاقي عايز تكمل في
الهوايه بتاعتك اللي كنت بتعملها ده
اختيار كان مهم جدا
مرحله الجيش هي بقى الفتره الحقيقيه اللي
انا بقيت فيها القناه انا كده كده ما كنتش
اعرف اصور فلوجات او يومياتي في الجيش
معروفه يعني
فقلت لفتره في الجيش دي السنه دي انا هعمل
بس يعني مش هعمل حاجه يعني قناتي اكل وقد
كان زي ما انتم شايفين كده هتلاقوا
الارقام ايه في مليون حاجات كده حاجات
غريبه
حسيت فعلا ان انا بعمل حاجه بحبها جدا مع
كنت انت اصلا انا برضو بحبه في نفس الوقت
والناس حبيته جدا
وكل ده انا لسه في فكره ان انا تمام انا
شغال انا حلو انا يعني انا في الجيش انا
واخد اجازه من الحياه يعني بعمل فيديوهات
اكل وفي الجيش
بس حبيت اطور شويه مثلا بس احسن مش عارف
برجر واحسن بيتزا ده حاولت اعمل افكار
تانيه زي تاكل ايه منه ومش عارف ايه يعني
حاولت اعمل افكار مختلفه شويه بحيس انا
انا بعملها بمزاجي يعني انا مش ما فيش
حاجه معينه بس في نفس الوقت بقى في الجيش
كانت الفتره اللي انا خطبت فيها فمحتاج
اعمل فلوس فالحمد لله ربنا رزقني شويه
شويه في اليوتيوب بقى الموضوع يمشي يمشي
يمشي يمشي ودي كانت حاجه مهمه يعني كانت
حاجه الصراحه محافظينها افضل مكمل في
اليوتيوب وانا في الجيش
اختيار الكارير خلصت الجيش حلو تمام هتعمل
ايه بقى انا كنت فاطر اشتغلت مواعيد في
الجامعه وفي نفس الوقت في يوتيوب بعمل
يعني على اليوتيوب هنا برضو في هنا يعني
في اختيار مهم انت هتختاره انت عايز تكمل
في ايه فبرده الحلو يعني هيديك مجرد نصيحه
يعني انا بحب دايما لما بتكلم حتى مع حد
ولي امر او كده خليك جايد ما تحكمش في
مسار معين
بس في الاخر ده بيربي عندك انت بشكل عام
فكرك تتحمل
مسئوليه قهارك ده انت في اخر انت اللي
هتعيش الحياه دي فانت اللي في الاخر انا
خلاص انا تمام لو حصل حاجه انا ما فيش ما
فيش حاجه تمام حلو
فانا اخترت ان انا اكمل في كريم بتاع
التصوير لان انا اكمل في يوتيوب وبدا
وقتها شويه شويه الايه الفيديوهات تبدا
تعمل صدى حلو جدا بقى في دخل شويه من
يوتيوب ما كانش فيه دخل زي ما شفتم في
الاول يعني الموضوع الاول انا اول 100
دولار اخذتها من يوتيوب مثلا كان بعد
سنتين وتلاته اشهر حاجه كده وقتها حتى
الدولار ما كانش بالرقم دلوقتي يعني بس
انا ما كنتش داخل يوتيوب داخل عشان انا
بحب اعمل فيديوهات ولما دخلت الحاجه فعلا
اللي بحبها وكملت فيها اعتقد ان انا بدات
فيها بشكل
لسه راجع من الامارات وعمارات
عايز اطور اطورت الكاميرا في الثانيه في
الثالثه عايز اجيب كمبيوتر اثنين ثلاثه
عدسه عدستين ثلاثه عايز اكبر الموضوع مش
الموضوع فكره فيديوهات كده وخلاص لا انا
عايز اخد الموضوع
فالفكره انا كان نفسي في يوم في الوقفه دي
مثلا في اليابان او زي دي مثلا في
الامارات خليفه انا كان نفسي اسافر نفسي
اعمل فيديوهات
وفكره ان انت خلاص اخترت حاجه ومركز فيها
قوي وفي ناس حواليك بتساعدك وبتعملك سبورت
ده مهم جدا بس انت في الاخر تبقى فاكر
وفاهم كويس قوي ان انت تحمل نتيجه قرارك
ده شكرا
[تصفيق]